with the bulk of the series in the
rearview mirror disney plus's one
division refuses to let up
episode 8 shed some light onto wanda's
past how her hex came to be
and why plus so many witches
here's the end of episode 8 explained
previously on
doesn't open in the sitcom-inspired
fashion of most
previous wand vision episodes instead
opting to kick off with a flashback
the year is 1693 in the town of salem
massachusetts where a covet of witches
punishes agatha for her crimes
according to her mother agatha betrayed
them by seeking knowledge that was
forbidden
and delved into dark magic breaking the
coven's rules
they attempt to use their combined
strength against her but
agatha is far too strong defeating her
fellow witches and taking their power
their lives and her mother's brooch
which we've seen her wear on just about
every episode of the show this scene
defines agatha
and it also reveals pretty much exactly
what she wants from wanda
she's power hungry and knows that
wanda's power
is unmatched that's why she's in
westview
agatha is going to do everything she can
to extract
what magical power she can from wanda
additionally it shows how far she has
come in her studies
gleefully demonstrating her magical
gifts to wanda without a moment of
hesitation
also it's a fine way to call back to
agatha harkness's origins in marvel
comics where she lived through the salem
witch trials
much like in one division comics agatha
survives
well into the modern day and continues
to practice her craft
she eventually befriends wanda becoming
her mentor
and helping her hone her oftentimes
uncontrollable abilities
while it doesn't appear as though agatha
will take wanda on as a pupil by next
week's episode you can't
exactly rule it out after all anything
can happen in one division and the mcu
in hopes of unlocking the secret to
wanda's immense power
and possibly finding a way to take it
herself agatha leads wanda on an
emotional journey throughout her
memories
sort of an mcu style tribute to another
classic tv show
this is your life sokovia is the first
stop to witness the death of wanda's
parents
they then jump to her time as a hydra
test subject then the rough time frame
between avengers age of ultron
and captain america civil war before
winding up
in westview pre-hex aside from wanda
herself
the through line that runs along each of
these flashbacks is the persistent
presence of classic television and
wanda's relationship to it
from the dick van dyke show to malcolm
in the middle wanda has always found
solace in fun
cheesy tv simply put it's the one
constant in wanda's life sticking around
when
everyone she's ever cared about is dead
and gone
this explains why the hex takes on these
tv inspired appearances
wanda's deepest wish is for her life to
be a lot more like a television show
with her husband vision at her side
it's hard to deny that dealing with
shenanigans that can be resolved in 30
minutes is
a whole lot better than facing reality
toward the end of wanda and agatha's
jaunt down memory lane viewers witnessed
how wanda first came to know
sword and what they were up to with
vision's corpse shortly after returning
to life from the blip
a grieving wanda marches into swords
headquarters hoping to give vision a
proper burial
in response to her arrival director
tyler hayward
puts the synthesoid's disassembled body
on full
display however he doesn't just hand
vision over to her
causing wanda to storm off she drives
off to west view new jersey which at the
time
is a normal town with plenty of
unassuming residents whom
viewers have grown quite familiar with
wanda arrives at the foundation of a
house with the deed to the property she
envisioned owned
indicating they would have built their
forever home in that spot
stricken with grief over what will never
be wanda releases
a huge amount of energy building her
house and turning the entire town
into a black and white 1950s sitcom set
this is the obvious beginning of
westview's time under wanda's influence
making it clear that she's responsible
for the hex's creation
to make the situation even more shocking
we learn here that wanda never actually
stole vision's body as hayward
previously alleged
nine days ago maximoff stormed our
facility
stole the vision's body and resurrected
him
she actually manifested a version of her
own to exist
solely within westview hence why he
couldn't escape so easily in episode 6
all new halloween spooktacular since
westview vision is
technically a creation of wanda's
imagination
that explains why he's not only alive
and well but was also
devoid of his memories until darcy's
history lesson
wanda killed me yes
but it's not that simple you asked her
to do it
why would i have done that juan
disabilities on the big screen have
grown more and more ill-defined as the
years have gone
on what exactly she can do and what the
mind stone actually did to her have
remained a mystery for some time
thankfully one division has begun to set
the record straight in a
major way beginning with a flashback
sequence in the hydra laboratory when
wanda encounters loki's scepter
the crystal levitates out of it gliding
in front of her face
it then expels a burst of energy and the
silhouette of an angelic being
briefly appears in its glow before
disappearing entirely
without any context this moment raises
plenty of questions on its own
many of which get an answer in some form
later on thanks to agatha's exposition
you're supposed to be a myth of being
capable of spontaneous creation
agatha then notes that in creating and
living within westview
wanda utilized chaos magic agatha warns
her of the dangers of chaos magic then
refers to her
as the scarlet witch the first time
wanda has been called this in the mcu
it's fairly common knowledge that
wanda's comic book alter ego is the
scarlet witch
and the being she saw in the mind stone
definitely resembled her comic book
appearance but
chaos magic is the lesser known element
of her character
when the scarlet witch first arrived on
the page creator stan lee and jack kirby
didn't wreck their brains trying to
explain her strengths
ultimately leaving them pretty vague
years later
chaos magic made its presence felt in
the marvel comics world
and was described as a type of sorcery
that alters the fabric of reality and
theoretically has the capabilities to
destroy it all together
this was retroactively applied to the
scarlet witch to better explain the true
depths of her powers
given the way one division has played
out it's fair to say elizabeth olsen's
interpretation of wanda maximoff is now
closer to her comic book counterpart
than
ever before in keeping with mcu
tradition
this week's one division adventure
included a post-credits scene
shifting the focus away from wanda and
agatha the series offers curious fans a
glimpse into what director hayward and
his sword underlings have been up to
and the reveal is creepy using the
remains of the original vision which
again
hayward has had this whole time despite
lying about wanda stealing them
hayward and his team have brought him
back online now with a white color
scheme
he doesn't speak or do much of anything
aside from open his
piercing blue eyes and become acquainted
with his new form
for long time marvel comics readers
easter eggs like this
are impossible to ignore the west coast
avengers number 42 kicks off
the vision quest plotline at the center
of which is the disappearance of vision
and
various heroes attempts to find him they
do just
that but he's in pieces so tech genius
hank pym is tasked with bringing him
back from beyond the grave
he does so but the neo vision takes on a
ghostly
white appearance and lacks all of the
emotional development of his previous
self
what hayward has in mind for his vision
how the
reanimated synthesis will behave and
what wanda's reaction to
white vision will be are certainly
things worth keeping an
eye out for in the season finale
previously on
turned out to be a fairly self-contained
story focusing largely on two main
characters
many one division mainstays were
conspicuous by their absence this time
around
as far as audience knowledge goes jimmy
is still outside of the expanded and
fortified hex likely trying to figure
out what happened to his allies
on the other hand when it comes to
monica and pietro things get a
bit more complicated the last fans saw
of monica she began to tap into her
newfound powers before agatha's faux
quicksilver confronted her outside of
the witch's home
meanwhile agatha also revealed that
she's not controlling this new version
of pietro
that was you no it wasn't literally me
just my
eyes and ears a cristal possession
that leaves lots of questions open about
just who he is and
where he's from questions that will
hopefully be answered in the next
and final episode as for darcy for all
anyone knows she's still sitting at that
intersection her foot on the brake of a
funnel cake truck
i'll just meet you there then the final
episode of one division hits disney plus
next week stay tuned check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about wand vision are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one